[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département aujourd'hui mercredi 3
mai parole à sylvaine pomonti principal
adjoint du collège la clé de
saint-pierre l encours et coordinateur
de la deuxième édition du sky robe le
challenge robotique de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines et
d'elancourt est organisée demain 9
communes seront représentées et plus de
800 élèves présents pour l'événement
parole aussi dans cette émission à
marilyn luz yeux secrétaire du collectif
pour la semaine de la mémoire de
l'esclavagé de saint quentin en yvelines
la neuvième édition de cette semaine
spéciale débute demain avec au programme
du cinéma des expositions du sport et
des conférences fil rouge cette année
les figures féminines de la résistance
mais pour débuter à cette émission je me
tourne vers vous sylvaine up aux monty
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes du coup en
charge de l'organisation de cette
deuxième édition du sky robe je ne sais
pas comment disque ayo scraire sky robe
aussi appelé challenge robotique c'est
plus simple à l'événement qui a lieu
demain jeudi 4 mai au prisme à elles
encourent trente sept classes seront
présentes pour l'occasion 800
participants ce qui fait beaucoup tout
de même et 9 villes qui participent du
bassin de saint quentin en yvelines
j'ai envie de vous poser la question 800
élèves est ce que vous êtes prêts à les
accueillir demain au prisme à elancourt
est-ce que tout est prêt le parcours
notamment alors eu le parcours est prêt
donc c'est pas tout à fait 37 37 15
participants de cette année puisqu'on a
23 équipes qui font ça d'accord demain
donc oui le parcours est prêt on est
prêt à accueillir au prisme tous ces
élèves qui vont venir en fait par vagues
successives va pas pouvoir tout soit
l'accueillir en même temps alors je veux
parler de parcours le challenge
robotique est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer concrètement en quoi ça
consiste qu'est ce que vont faire les
élèves demain au prisme elle encore
alors demain en fait qu'ils vont faire
c'est qu'ils vont faire évoluer un robot
qui de leur choix sur un parcours donc
un parcours soit un parcours imposé qui
est déjà proposé soit un parcours libre
qu'on appelle le parcours artistique
on envoie quelques unes
j'allais quand c'était la saison passée
donc ça c'est l'édition de l'année
dernière en effet donc l'année dernière
comme cette année parcours libre ou
parcours imposé comme vous voyez alors
précisons que ce sont des robots que les
élèves les classes ont elles même
préparé alors pas forcément puisque vous
avez on a des classes de la moyenne
section jusqu'à la seconde donc à la
moyenne section
alors forcément de construire leur leurs
robots donc en fait ils peuvent soit
utilisé un robot spécialement dédié à
l'éducation soit un robot effectivement
qu'ils construisent les plus grands
construit souvent leur roubaud or
justement les plus grands qui ont
construit leur robot qu'elles ce qu'ils
ont appris pendant c'est peut-être ces
semaines où c'est moins durant ils ont
sur lesquels ils ont travaillé sur le
sur leurs blousons aprilia a programmé
alors déjà dans un premier temps
effectivement il faut apprendre à
programmer le robot il faut apprendre à
programmer le robot sur un parcours ce
qui nécessite quand même quelques
adaptations des c'est une façon ludique
en fait d'initier les élèves au codage
et la programmation justement j'allais
vous demandez l'objectif de ce challenge
c'est d'apprendre aux enfants à devenir
les futurs rois de la robotique
alors peut-être pas les rois de la
programme delà de la robotique mais
certainement en tout cas c'est un moyen
d'intéresser les élèves dès leur plus
jeune âge à la programmation et à la
robotique avait quelque chose de concret
réalisations concrètes
et puis pour les plus grands si c'est un
moyen de prévenir le décrochage scolaire
parce que c'est vrai qu'on s'est rendu
compte que cette application concrète de
la programmation ça a aidé aussi ça
m'intéressait énormément nos élèves et
ça les aider à rester scolarisés
j'allais vous poser la question est-ce
que c'est aussi un moyen déguisé un peu
de leur faire faire des mathématiques de
la science à travers cette utilisation
des robots qui les intéressent vous le
disiez oui alors c'est vrai que
donc en par exemple dans leur plus jeune
âge on se rend compte que toutes les
disciplines peuvent s'adapter à
l'utilisation de la robotique on peut
faire un peu mettre la robotique en fait
à beaucoup de beaucoup de discipline a
beaucoup de choses différentes
et puis quand ils sont plus grands
effectivement ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les enseignements
pluridisciplinaires et disciplinaires
enfin c'est pas tout à fait ça mais les
deux pays
donc ça permet en fait aux élèves de
travailler différentes disciplines et
différentes compétences à travers la
robotique alors on sait que la commune
d'hallencourt est à la pointe on va dire
sur l'enseignement de la robotique dans
ses écoles dans ces collèges
est ce que vous pensez qu aujourd'hui
concrètement tous les élèves de collège
en 2010 elles devraient avoir accès à
cet enseignement là à côté évidemment
des enseignements traditionnels est ce
que c'est devenu essentiel pour pour
leur futur alors c'est tellement devenu
essentiel que l'apprentissage du code
est maintenant inscrit dans les
programmes de l'éducation nationale à
partir du cours élémentaire
donc c'est vrai que c'est considéré
aujourd'hui comme quelque chose
d'essentiel un enseignement
alors pour revenir sur ce concours
organisé demain au prisme à partir ce
jeudi 4 mai au prisme entre 9h et 16h30
puisqu'on parle d'un challenge qui
seront les arbitres ou les juges
éventuel est-ce qu'il y en aura alors
bien sûr on a des juges dont qui sont le
jury composé de professionnels qui sont
issus du monde de l'entreprise en
particulier d'entreprises locales
et puis de membres évidemment de
l'éducation nationale d'accord donc
parmi les entreprises locales
représentées on à airbus ont hâte à
l'aise par rapport par l'intermédiaire
de l'association elles bougent que nous
avons sollicité pour faire partie du
jury
d'accord ce seront uniquement les
enfants on le rappelle qui participeront
à ce challenge les adultes sont
uniquement spectateur alors les adultes
encadrent puisque les enfants ne sont
pas tout seuls sur le parcours ils sont
encadrés par leurs enseignants les
enseignants nantes encadré et appris à
programmer les robots ont reçu pendant
toute l'année donc on va pas non plus
les mettre de côté tout de suite y
seront bien évidemment présents sur le
plateau avec l'or
avec leurs élèves alors c'est la
deuxième édition comment comment vous
vous sentez les enfants est-ce qu'ils
sont intéressés par la chose est ce qu
ils le sont tous est-ce que aussi les
professeurs puissent qu'ils appellent
même à programmer sont intéressés
également est ce que vous sentez une
émulation pour ce pour ce programme là
alors totalement il y avait lieu pareil
sur le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines au lycée dumont-d'urville le
forum des usages numériques ou beaucoup
justement des enseignants qui encadrent
des classes qui participent au challenge
cette année ont témoigné et c'est vrai
qu'on sent un vrai comment dire un vrai
effort est un vrai plaisir à la fois des
enseignants et des élèves s'intéresser à
la robotique très bien merci
sylvia puis monter pour toutes ces
informations concernant le skyrock pour
cette deuxième édition et puis la
rédaction de tv fil 78 tu sera là demain
jeudi 4 mai au prisme est elle en cours
et vous aurez du coup un reportage
complet sur cet événement dans nos
prochaines éditions merci beaucoup
[Musique]
on poursuit cette émission avec un
nouvel invité une nouvelle invitée
plutôt marilyn les yeux bon soit vous
êtes la secrétaire du collectif pour la
semaine de la mémoire de l'esclavagé de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est le nom
complet une semaine que vous organisé
tous les ans entre le 4 et le 10 mai
cette année c'est la neuvième édition et
puis peut-être un peu d'histoire déjà
pour commencer la choix le choix des
dalles plutôt du 4 au 10 mai n'est pas
n'est pas le fruit du hasard
alors nous nous souhaitions plutôt que
de rester sur une date unique à qui la
date nationale de 10 mai accompagnés
le public vers sète cette date est
terminée en apothéose avec cette date là
pour que justement ce ne soit pas juste
une journée de commémoration ou quelques
minutes de commémoration propos de voix
là et qu'ils soient très rapidement
oubliée alors vous vous organisez une
semaine complète qui débute ce jeudi 4
mai avec de nombreuses manifestations
aura l'occasion de revenir dessus mais
expliquez nous déjà quel est l'objectif
principal de cette semaine c'est
c'est de faire vivre le leur ce devoir
de mémoire
oui c'est c'est important de poursuivre
d'accompagner autrement 1 c'est dans les
programmes scolaires à l'école primaire
toutefois ces quelques heures et nous
nous essayons d'aborder ce sujet sur
différents angles et puis il ya comment
dirais-je d'autres aspects que nous
pouvons creuser et accompagner tout au
long de l'année et a d'ailleurs
avec avec le temps nous nous
accompagnons même toute l'année puisque
nous avons un atelier qui s'appellerait
créa qui fonctionne tout au long de
l'année et où
les romands diraient les les expositions
en tous cas l'exposition phare de
l'année se prépare pendant tout au long
de l'année pour ensuite être disponibles
lors de la semaine selon vous
aujourd'hui l'enseignement l'histoire de
l'esclavagé a été aboli officiellement
en france en 1848 et enseigner un peu
trop sommairement
disons qu'il est enseigné deux manières
académique nous ça nous permet de
prendre d'autres angles comme je vous
disais et puis surtout c'est un sujet
qui n'est pas attractif on ne va pas se
vanter d'avoir des ancêtres esclaves
or il est important à la fois que cette
cette partie de l'histoire soit partagé
non pas sous l'aspect de la
revendication de la réparation parce
qu'on ne saurait pas véritablement
comment travailler cette réparation mais
surtout d'une appropriation comme une
donnée des figures mythiques à ses
descendants
d'esclaves et permettre aux autres on va
dire descendants de colo de se rendre
compte qu'il y avait aussi des figures
mythiques dans le peuple noir et ça peut
aider éventuellement au mieux vivre
ensemble sont exactement c'est vraiment
l'objectif c'est vraiment l'objectif que
nous poursuivons depuis la création de
ce de ce comité et même auparavant quand
nous fonctionnons que sur une seule
journée et même avant qu'il n'y ait
cette cette date retenue nationalement
alors à chaque édition vous avez un fil
rouge et pour cette neuvième année ce
sont les femmes
vous dites sur votre site internet quels
sont les oubliés de l'histoire de
l'esclavagé mais de toute l'histoire
jeudi soir de toute l'histoire
si on regarde bien on va montrer une
femme peut être
en arrière-plan de grands de grands
hommes politiques mais alors rarement du
cours d'histoire est ce que vous
pourriez vous nous présenter très
rapidement au moins nous donner le
prénom est long le nom d'une femme
mythique i qui s'est battu toute sa vie
pour la lutte contre énorme sur la
guadeloupe
on aura enfin là comment dirais-je la
guadeloupe célèbre mulâtresse solitude
qui est s'est battu jusqu'au et qui a
laissé sa vie puisqu'elle a été exécuté
et qui parce qu elle ne l a lutté contre
le rétablissement de l'esclavagé vous
savez qu'il ya eu une première abolition
est ensemble disait voilà et ensuite un
rétablissement par par napoléon est donc
cette comme on dirait ce groupe n'a
absolument pas accepter et en
particulier donc mulâtresse solitude qui
qui a lutté quitte à part qui n'a pas
fléchi
on va on va terminer peut être pas par
parler quand même tube de demain ce
jeudi 4 mai la trappe avec une rencontre
avec des élèves c'est ça attrape anatole
france et aussi nous avons voilà nous
avons à coeur de toujours associer les
élèves ont donc c'est un partenariat qui
s'inscrit avec les échanges et les
contacts qu'on nous au fil des éditions
avec donc les médiathèques les centres
comment dirais-je pas les centres de
loisirs mais les maisons de quartier et
les écoles qui souhaitent qu'il soit
bien entendu on va donner un autre temps
fort puisque le temps précisément un
autre temps fort c'est samedi
cette fois ci à la salle du conseil
d'agglomération rattrape là il y aura
plusieurs événements une exposition une
table ronde et une conférence voilà
c'est ça et c'est vrai que c'est c'est
cet aspect de conférence est toujours
assez problématique de rallier les
comment dirais-je le public donc c'est
important de venir aussi
écoutez c'est échanger et être confronté
à des personnes qui ont fait des
recherches beaucoup plus approfondie et
qui peuvent apporter des solutions ou en
tout cas des réponses on est
malheureusement un peu près le temps je
suis je pas rapidement alors autre temps
fort justement le milieu du sport il
faut vraiment être le lundi 8 mai il y à
du sport le mercredi 10 mais il ya un
spectacle notamment au scarabée la
verrière en tout cas toutes les
informations on va le voir s'afficher à
l'écran sur le programme et notamment
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de votre écran voilà désolé pour des
draps venez nombreux nous avons besoin
de soutien et vous vous ne commande et
vous ne perdrez pas votre temps
surtout s'il pleut comme comme en ce
moment merci marie line l'usure pour
toutes ces informations et puis rendez
vous sur votre site internet du coup
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
pour ce soir prochain rendez vous demain
d'ici là retrouvez toutes nos séquences
en replay sur notre site internet où
notre application
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]